hallo ich meine lieben villages und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge happy meals ich habe mir gedacht
die letzte happy meals folge ist locker
schon ein jahr her deswegen nehme ich
das ganze einfach noch mal auf ich hab
die steuerung schon so halb wieder
verlernt aber ich denke wir fangen
einfach erstmal mit diesem feature
travels hier an mit subway ok
anscheinend wir sind in dieser bahn und
der hat gerade geschrieben bekommen
das ist mcdonald's mcdonalds
diese spieler sich einfach kein bisschen
verändert aber das war uns natürlich
viel zu einfach wir spielen jetzt denn
irgendwelche kohlleppel ideen habt könnt
ihr mir die auch einfach zu senden und
zwar ihr könnt den level machen dass
ihnen die kontrakte nennen oder so dann
spiele ich das vielleicht glaub ich muss
die bauen wir hier so ein bisschen hoch
halten
ach ich musste ihm rüber kicken nein
da sie jedoch nein ok ich glaube ich
habe die perfekte taktik siehst du
siehst du ok der ist ja richtig gut das
ist ein richtiger profi in diesem spiel
anschauen
ja der war der spitze den kriegt er
nicht
die explains why wo bin ich versuche
jetzt mal eventuell schaffen wir das
ganze auch ohne dass wir uns ein bein
brechen
das wäre natürlich ein vorteil erst mal
lesen hier ok caps 0 72
guckt euch mal was ist das für ein viel
da oben okay ich bin ein fahrstuhl ich
will ja eigentlich gar nicht weiter ist
ein komischer typ an der wand und der
sperre in sich drin
das hatte ich schon immer probleme mit
dem darüber sprechen welche sachen so ok
freedom okay ich fahre hier einfach
zurück dass wir immer irgendein
körperteil verlieren müssen da hängt
schon wieder so eine forsche herum alter
ist es denn war hier die tür ist
anscheinend jetzt aktiviert gate
activated das heißt wir müssen irgendwie
dazu einfach wieder zurück ich habe mein
bein ja auch schon verloren
ich fahre mir über meine eigenen beine
das hat sich richtig an okay die roboter
haben die weltherrschaft übernommen und
wir sollen die irgendwie zerstören ohne
beine okay ich komme halt nicht mal hoch
und ich schaffe das
das ist ja mal ich also dass diese
grafik ist ja echt mal da muss man sagen
heute so sieht es übrigens aus wenn
regenzeit liegestützen machen wir das
ganze noch mal es wenn man mit seinem
speed runs so wir sind schon wieder im
fahrstuhl wer hätte gedacht dass wir
hier so schnell vorankommt springt
einfach mal hier rüber
sie hat so ruckelt noch ein bisschen ich
muss das ganze noch ein bisschen pop
titel you die theorie und jetzt fahren
das ganze wieder zurück jetzt gebe hier
nämlich runter in den noch rein und da
ist schon das erste beinahe 80 auch
irgendeine taste die einen sagen kann
dass man nicht so nicht so viel falsch
schaden nimmt oder sowie das ist richtig
gut werden noch nahezu gar keinen fall
schaden bekommen und jetzt hier haben
wir auch geschafft okay da wo sind wir
wo sind wir wir sind wieder in echten
welt
eine
dazu mal sagen soll das ist doch kanzler
war sein kann er sich dann noch er kann
sich halt nicht mal mehr bewegen sich
happy wheels and rear wheels freuen ich
habe jetzt gesagt ein level versuche man
noch damit die folgen nicht ganz so lang
wird und ich eventuell er in zukunft
auch eure level spielen kann
deswegen klicken auch namen für diesen
kleinen jungen schreibt mir mein name in
die kommentare wie viel man kann auch
nicht irgendwie sowas wie villiger aber
so einen richtigen namen verdiene mir
den namen
ich will den namen balu ganz cool du
passt nicht zusammen
was ist das denn bitte nicht angucken
wir machen jetzt den kleinen trick
einfach mal damit wir hier schnell
weiterkommen und zwar den hier machen
einen tollen ausflug da passieren
komische dinge aber wie man es einfach
die richtige discopop bei der so viel
bizeps aller die sind schon die ganze
zeit einfach an wackeln er will einfach
zurück ins fitnessstudio
okay da ist eine axt ich fasse es nicht
sein war sein freunde kann es dann war
ich drück halt nichts und er macht das
guck mal was er von alleine macht habe
ich denn hier für leute erwischen sieht
das halt auch bei mir mal aus wenn wenn
ich meinem vater irgendwo unterwegs war
so hat das ganze dann immer geändert
nicht sein wir müssen jetzt irgendwie
mal ein ganzes system im iran bringen so
wir sind jetzt hier drehen und müssen
jetzt irgendwie der region global bier
ich mache einfach mal so ich bin draußen
da ist die axt aber weggekickt von jetzt
hier einfach mal als pete rock on aktion
war ja einfach mal ganz schnell
letzter versuch freunde wir sind jetzt
in diesem raum drin
ich würde sagen wir steuern erstmal auf
thema tabu
mir geht spitze kann snps ändert weil
ich sehr los mit diesem level ich weiß
ich bin nicht gut in diesem spiel aber
eventuell findet ihr das ja gerade wenn
ich da drin nicht gut bin schreibt man
die kommentare ob ich mehr davon sehen
wollt und wir machen das jetzt einfach
mal
wir nehmen einfach den tisch mit nach
draußen warum machen wir nicht so wir
können doch einfach mal da ist gar nicht
so die achse ist weg jetzt irgendwie
schnell über die brücke wir haben über
die brücke geschafft ich will gar nicht
wissen was in diesem level hersteller
vor sich geht was der hier so alles
macht es wieder eine axt licht gerade
haben wir natürlich schnell dann vorbei
wir fanden wenig gemein card rum und
seen böse teile und fahren einfach
weiter mit dem fahrrad und hoffen mal
dass wir nicht irgendwie sterben oder so
das wars mit dieser folge happy meals
wenn ihr bock darauf habe dass ich mehr
happy meals mache und das ganze auch auf
das hochladen und auch so bearbeitet
dann zeigt es mir mit einer bewertung